so thank you all for still being here
for the very last talk of this workshop
and this is a joint work with Chi how is
also here is graduating this year and
yeah this talk is about the tractability
of class of counting problems on a class
of graphs so an important class of
counting problems are spin systems and
in a spin system we had given a graph
and each vertex is a variable taking
edges taking values from from Q possible
colors or states and each edge is a
binary constraint so the weight of of a
configuration is given by this product
and the partition function is is this
total weight of for all configurations
so this talk is about Holland problems
the Holland problem is an HP model so
each edge is a variable and each vertex
is a constraint and the Holland is this
sum of product so now so now each
constraint function also called a
signature may be defined on a very large
number of variables if your graph has
unbounded degree and also the size of
the the size of the configuration space
is a lot bigger its q2 the number of
edges
in fact its spin system it is well known
that a spin system can be represented as
Holland in incidence graph with equality
signature on the word vertex side and
the binary constraint on the other side
in this way Holland can simulate any
csps and so this is counting matchings
it's a typical Holland problem so with
signature at most one function its 1 1
or 0 so remember that for symmetric
functions with Poland domain we can
represent a signature as this so fi
gives them the function value of of
input with precisely I ones so this is
counting perfect matchings the signature
is the exactly one function and this is
counting edge covers the signature is at
least one function 0 or 1 and this is
the sub graphs world problem from Jeremy
Sinclair's Markov chain for
ferromagnetic easy model and I omitted
the edge wait here so the signature is
this parity function depending on the
parity of the input the signature
returns either value 1 or video Oh make
value mu let's see so yeah I thought
your you must be already there Tyler at
at this point so i made this talk very
easy so you have a equality which is
like this ok
and you have matching like this perfect
matching
edge cover
this is the parody okay which is like a
bee a bee and the last one is hunting
Alerian orientation in the incidence
graph with this dis equality signature
it it enforces that your configuration
must be a orientation of edges and I'm
sorry on this side this signature I call
it oil Aryan signature it except the
input with equal number of zeros and
ones so just another color this is all
area
so this one is this plus the signature
is fundamentally different from all the
others okay tell why tell you because
these signatures although with unbounded
degree they all can be similar can be
computed computed by a fixer sorry by a
finite state automaton sitting at the
vertex revealing the state of edge one
by one not this last one so so the
motivation of this project is that it
seems like Holland problems and not just
them more expressive than spin systems
yes supposed to be more difficult to
compute in general than spin systems and
we want to give a class of nice Holland
problems which are not so harder than
spin systems but what we mean by being
more difficult to compute so they are
both number P complete right so before
going there I want to mention this
notion of trees so the trivia is a
parameter a structural parameter of
graphs which measures how much at graph
is like a tree so the trivia of the tree
is one and the trivias of creek is minus
one
so remember that the classic algorithms
like belief propagation work very well
on cheese so yeah it's natural to
consider graphs which are like trees and
indeed by crocell theorem in logic spin
systems are fixed parameter tractable
entryways and the actual running time
achieved by the junction tree belief
propagation in artificial intelligence
is exponential of trees as for spin and
the for holland if your graph has spun
dated maximum degree then the same time
bound up is achieved by it is achieved
in in the context of tensor networks in
quantum computing so let me briefly
explain why bonded freeways helps County
okay so usually such algorithms are
dynamic programming on 3d conversation
but I don't want to go into detail about
shitty compositions and normal forms I
prefer to use another kind of graph
decomposition here which is less popular
but more intuitive to me I call this
separator decomposition given a graph
the separator decomposition of that
graph is a binary tree we are every tree
node a corresponding to a vertical set
and with the root corresponding to the
entire vertex set V and for note we are
corresponding to vertex at VI it has
vertex separator SI so VI is separated
into disconnected vertex sets Vijay and
vacay which corresponding to its
children and we recursively do that
and to you in the leaves the sets are
empty the width of this decomposition is
the maximum size of the separator the
vertex separator also the vertex
boundary of each vertex set and the
optimal the optimal width of this
decomposition is the width of the
optimal such decomposition of a graph
denoted as SW of of graph of G so
imagine a few graph is already a tree
then the separator should be the root
and every node in the D conversation is
a sub tree or a sub for sub forest right
so the decomposition of this thing at
the wheels of this decomposition is is
exactly one because it's a tree ok it's
quite standard to prove that the wii's
this notion of which is asymptotically
equal to the tree with and also
constructing an optimal decompensation
is fixed the pyramid retractable entry
entry ways ok so now with this kind of
decomposition it's almost a you know
immediate to get an dynamic programming
algorithm for computing the partition
function of spin systems so given any
vertex set VI we can recursively compute
the partition function of the sub graph
induced by this by this vertex set with
an arbitrary boundary condition by
enumerate all the possible
configurations at the
separator and then taking the product of
these three parts the partition function
of the left a child a partition function
of the right child and the contribution
of the separator itself and this third
part can be evaluated directly on site
because every spin here is fixed and
these two things are just a recursive
quantity so this is actually a tree
recursion a computation tree on the
decomposition of graph and the product
here is due to the same conditional
independence property of spin system
where you know conditioning the
separator being fixed the disconnected a
components independent of each other and
the tree with gives upper bound on the
size of the separator as well as the
size of the boundary so we smoke through
with this enumeration is efficient and
also this recursion can be implemented
as efficient dynamical program so that
explain why true true is helps counting
in the in models with such local
Markovian properties like spin system
so the Holland if you know now edges are
variables and so we can enumerate edge
states and also here is the edge
boundary so if your graph has sponded
degree it's fine because that won't
change your time complexity too much but
in general graph with unbounded degree
with for General Holland problems it's
it's very challenging it's very hard to
do that actually just a thing about for
general csps even if you know your graph
is already a tree untry how to come up
with a belief propagation or or tree
recursion without enumerated
exponentially many local configurations
we don't know how to do that right so
yeah so generous ASP or Holland can be
very different from Steve so back to our
ago of classifying the computational
complexity of Holland problems according
to the graph family and the signature
family we here we gave a class of nice
Holland problems which are close to spin
systems in computation in the sense that
so these Holland problems can be
computed in time exponential of n n is
the number of vertices instead of edges
and also these Holland problems are
fixed parameter tractable in true with
these two are closely connected and this
exponential of truest time boundaries is
crucial because it it has certain
implications in approximate counting in
planar graphs so let me formally
described this this characterization of
nice Holland problems like like these
new ones
so
for now we just assume our signature is
symmetric symmetric function for any
partial assignment we can camp in this
function with this partial assignment
which means we fix the values of these
variables according to this partial
assignment tall this gives us our new
function right new k array function also
symmetric function so there are many
ways to pin this function it's possible
that many partial assignment produce the
same kre function think about this
function is a parity function so it for
any fixed okay it only gives us two
functions depending on the parity of the
partial assignment so that defines a
natural equivalent classes between
between partial inputs I call it peering
so the number of such equivalent classes
gives a natural measure of the
dimensionality intrinsic dimensionality
of symmetric function for parity
function it's just too so this leads us
to the key concept of our project so for
symmetric function f we call F our
regular if for any K the number of
number 46 viable KRA functions produce
that by pinning F is at most are okay so
yeah so no matter how we so once we fix
the cane no matter how we painting those
positions those variables the number of
different function it gives us is at
most K animals are sorry so for
symmetric function with boolean domain
with this signature form suppose the
special assignment has I once and the
jay-z rose and pinning this function
with this partial assignment delete I
entries from left and J entries from
right it gives us this interest of
interval as our new function actually
every pinning it gives us a sub interval
so being our regular means once we fix k
the number of different patterns of this
sliding window through lens k is at most
are so is this definition it's quite
easy to check all these functions are
are finitely regular only two regular
action and not this Euler in signature
even though it's very very simple almost
always unsatisfiable so yeah it's quite
amazing the regularity of this alerion
signature depends on the degree
so that m4 for symmetric function of
general domain like domain three the
signature is a simplex and so this sub
info becomes our sub simplex a smaller
simplex and so being our regular means
with this smaller simplex fixed size
fixed no matter how we move around and
the number of different patterns we can
get is at most are so we spun the degree
we always get finite regular
irregularity so bounded degree is just a
special case of this is regularity when
we show that for Holland problems
defined by our regular symmetric
function as our regular symmetric
signatures they can be computed in time
are to the 0 n n is the number of
vertices and also they are fixed the
parameter tractable in true is in our
so it means for for constant are these
Holland function these Holland problems
are like like spin systems with finite
state signatures they are like spin
systems so in our previous work this
base of the time bound is it was to
today our and now we improve it
exponentially to our and we believe this
is essentially tight in general assuming
the exponential time hypothesis and we
extend this result to assess metric
signatures but for metric signatures
with unbounded degree we must be careful
because it can be uncomfortable so we
make certain assumptions about that and
also this result has implications in
approximately counting on planar graphs
and in particular it gives the Peters
for log partition function and f Peters
for the partition function assuming the
decay of correlation both on planar
graphs
okay so let me first talk about this the
simple this exponential time algorithm
it's very very simple given the Holland
instance we assume an arbitrary ordering
of vertices we pick the very last vertex
we enumerate all possible configurations
on the edge on the in its incident edge
and this gives us a simple recursion for
the Holland right and the new holland
instances are defined on the on the
graph with n minus 1 vertices with new
signatures obtained from painting the
old signatures and by the regularity we
know that at each vertex the number of
the different possible signatures is
bounded by our and that's that's also
recursive so that recursively we need to
prove that but that's true so yeah this
immediately gave us this dynamic
programming because we can memorize all
the pollen instance with this dynamic
programming table of this size and it
gives us this runtime it's it's very
simple and for specific Holland problems
like permanent the running time can be
further optimized because we only in
your middle feasible configurations and
for permanent to the graph is bipartite
we can use that so actually this this is
very simple combinatorial airzone gives
our can compute the permanent in a
permanent of n by n matrix in time in
time n square times 2 to the M which is
very close to
to the running time of the risers
formula which is in sometimes to do and
yeah without using inversion technique
and yes so and to make this algorithm
works for general family of symmetric
functions we need to do some formal
works because we know for each vertex
once we fix the arity the number of
different signatures is bounded but we
still need to be able to efficiently
enumerate those signatures by a
succinctly representation and also we
need to evaluate and further painting
those signatures by referring to the 16
representations those are
functionalities are called Oracle's and
they can be realized by efficient data
structures for all symmetric functions
but for specific for Holland with
specific signatures the all these things
are implicit so yeah it's very simple
and next we move on to this fixed
parameter tractable algorithm for
Holland on graphs with only the truest
remember that we have this decomposition
of graphs that recursively separate
vertex set into smaller disconnected
vertexes sets via vga and BK
disconnected by this vertex separator SI
and the size of the separation also the
vertex boundary is sponded upper bounded
by trees so here the idea of the Arizona
is still similar that we just enumerate
all possible cases within this separator
but now it's really tricky because
Holland for Holland edges are our
variables and and also for vertex in the
middle in this separator it can be
adjacent to unbundling many edges how do
we do that but something is still finite
here for vertex for each vertex in the
middle although it may adjacent to
unbundling many edges those edges belong
to only three groups edges adjacent to
the left edges adjacent to the right
component and edges within the
separators within the separator and
remember that we have this notion of
equivalent classes for for partial
inputs and an observation is that the
function value can be fully determined
by the equivalent classes of the of the
partial input imaginate is still the
parrot function once we know the parity
of the three parts the function value is
determined and the parity of those three
parts just the equivalent classes for
the actual configurations of those part
so now you know what we should do right
so for each vertex in the middle in the
separator instead of enumerating all
possible configurations local
configurations of its adjacent edges we
enumerate the equivalent classes for
three groups of its edges parity
function is only eight possibility and
before by enumerating the actual
configuration these configuration
becomes boundary conditions for the new
instances inherited by the new incident
now because what we enumerate a not
configuration anymore they are
equivalent classes and if they are
equivalent classes so now those are not
boundary conditions but under
e-signatures so we represent to the
equivalent classes as a boolean
signature I call it Pierre appearing
function f so this signature just you
know except only those configurations
false fall in to the equivalent classes
it enforces like if it's all even odd
then this is is it this one just always
accepted other configurations okay so oh
and it's important to say that by this
translation of signatures the regularity
never never increases it never ruins the
regularity so so now we have this tree
recursion for Holland and yeah it for
each vertex in the middle it enumerated
equivalent classes of the three group of
adjacent edges and it you know just send
it to the children inherit by the
children in the new instance and as
boundary signatures and this third part
you know this third part is a Holland
defined on this separator and when we
enumerate two configurations this part
is easy to solve this tribute it's just
a product but now it's not trivial
because those are not configurations
those are our signatures so it's a
non-trivial Holland problem define on
this separator but the good thing is we
know that the instance the size of the
instance is bounded by trees so we can
apply our first terrorism which compute
the Holland and exponential type
exponential to the tree with so our to
the truest and we know all these those
peering signatures are still our regular
so so altogether it gives us dynamic
programming running and
I'm are to the order of true is x n
which is the size of the decompensation
so okay let's that's it so we still need
to do this former works to guarantee
those you know functionalities those
articles are efficient now we have a new
article which is peering Oracle
translate a signature to these boolean
signatures and we need to do some extra
work to make sure that you know
recursively do this translations will
not make the number of signatures
explode and yeah and that's true and
they can be efficiently implemented by
data structures for all symmetric
signatures so yeah so we have this
theorem so which says basically for
regular for Holland problem defined by
this finite state signatures they are
like spin systems that's only for
symmetric for now that's only for
symmetric signature for a symmetric
signature pin we can still pin the
function right but pinning must specify
the locations the position of pinning
and we can similarly define the notion
of for our regularity so a function as a
symmetric function is our regular if if
no matter how we fix the position of
pinning we fix the Precision's first
then no matter how we fix them once we
figure once we fix those locations no
matter how we pin those variables the
number of functions it produces is
funded by our okay so for each fixed set
of position no matter how we pin them
number function is funding so with this
definition all these results
can be extended to s magic signatures
with the same time bound but assuming
the availability of those Oracle's so
for symmetric signatures we can just
implement those articles it explicitly
but for a symmetric functions with
unbounded degree even evaluating those
functions can be undecidable so but we
believe that for sparse family of
officially computable functions make
such assumptions not so crazy yeah so
okay so so this result has certain some
implications and approximate counting on
planner graphs before planning graph we
know by bakers decomposition technique a
planar graph can be decomposed into a
sequence of sub graphs with spangly the
true with and it was discovered by
Jeremy Goldberg McQuillan that with
Baker's decomposition if we have a
subroutine to compute the Holland in
time exponential to the tree with then
so sorry for classes Holland for classes
Holland on planet graphs if the the
Holland is exponential always
exponentially large then we have a
Peter's for the log of Holland so for
spin system it's just a lot partition
function it's a it's very interest
interesting quantity by itself and
and so it means that the very strong
hotness result of sly cannot hold
anymore on planar graphs so so which so
this gives a separation between the the
computational complexity of approximate
counting planner graphs and on general
graphs it's very interesting phenomenon
yeah once we have planners structures we
cannot have such a strong concentration
and then the with correlation decay with
strong spatial mixing assuming the
strong spatial mixing which basically
says you can ignore any information
beyond the login ball to to give a you
know so the information within the login
boy is sufficient to approximate this a
marginal probability look at its
information it's a sufficiency of local
information it's it's not a an algorithm
but a planar graphs we know that the
trivets of log and ball is linear of log
in so with the subroutine which can
compute exactly which can do the exact
counting within time expand show for
true with the sphere this gives us our
polynomial time approximation algorithm
for the for the marginal probability and
for self reducible problems this gives
our F Peters for the Holland
so let's wrap up so we we locate a class
of nice Holland problems that behave
like hundred degree number sales people
like spin systems in this sense and they
have time complex this kind of time
complexity and this notion of regularity
implies efficient dynamic programming
algorithms but it's not preserved by
holographic transformation we still
don't understand what holographic
transformation does to this finite state
signature and also it does not cover
many other exact counting techniques
like inversion based their techniques a
principle of inclusion exclusion but we
saw that a it can achieve something
something similar it could be some
intrinsic connection there so and that
open problem is whether this is tight we
believe this is ty we believe that you
know you know this regularity can go up
goes up to 2 to n so we believe there
should be such lower bound there should
be Holland problem which is easy for
decision hard for counting with boolean
symmetric signature that has such into
the truest lower bound assuming the
exponential time hypothesis so far
there's no such lower bound so for the
fine grain lower bound I guess it's it's
only 2 to the truest most
4444 problem which is easy for 440
station so and by by by our discovery
such problem must be must have on Monday
the degree signature and must be
irregular so this alluring orientation
is nice King so yeah that's it thank you
and do you think you could do anything
at all similar for other graphic
parameters in particular for bounded
click with cases which seemed like this
should be tractable but unknown to be
there's only some exponential of
Britain's now yeah I think definitely
there there should be something there
but we're not experts on actually a
super structural graph theory so we can
do something you know something very
concrete but not that generic so yeah
but i guess the airship should be
something there for the cliq with ya
but you know for counting it seems like
a chew is somehow their natural yeah i
think it is it's difficult working with
ya
two remotes gone to this question
quickly doesn't seem to function because
already good at romantic polynomial or
the tough one Chris doesn't have so much
policy the other thing is that they
think when you quote coarser theorem of
1990 he only uses decision problems and
optimization problems if you want to do
grab parameter family's coyotes okay so
yeah yeah we'll make this correct sorry
yeah Lydia's
okay so your tongue but also the
organizers of this nice workshop and the
program then there's something